hey guys how's it going so today I'm
gonna make something and I am NOT going
to mess it up because Jenna and Matt hey
Eric I may come over I say guys I'm
making a really great treat and then I
make said treat and then it comes out
looking like a big pile of destruction
they're super easy
the little strawberries filled with
cheesecake I'm not gonna mess it up step
get your berries wash the berries this
is a lot of berries clearly you're not
going to need all of these have any
cream cheese powdered sugar heavy cream
chocolate graham cracker crumbs so that
step is to cut the tops off of the
strawberries and hollow them out so
we're gonna do I'm gonna hurt myself
what I'm gonna do
could be dangerous
his life is very sharp
well there's one this is going quickly
these are ah did right the skin thank
God
idiot cut like nature so I had to stop a
video because you're just taking me so
long to cut these so now that I have
them all cut I'm going to start
preparing the bottom mixture which is
basically just white chocolate so you
melt the white chocolate and then you
put some graham crackers on it to keep
it all nice and stable like me so stable
place the child in a small dish small
dish 50% power 15 yet ready yeah
sounds of cream cheese cutting it half
and then the whole just that's good I
know that's precise four tablespoons of
powdered sugar or three tablespoons of
heavy cream so one two three more or
less to taste beat until smooth bet it
smell that too much now everything's
have anyone to quickly put your little
graham crackers into the bag so you want
to dip your little strawberry into the
white chocolate and then into the graham
cracker like so cuz they're looking
really fancy so once you have your
cheesecake mixture mixed your
strawberries placed on your pan the
easiest way if you don't have a
decorating bag as you can throw it
inside of a ziplock bag which I'm gonna
do I do have a decorating bag but I've
absolutely no idea where it is so this
is what we're gonna do zip it up cut one
of these ends holy crap this actually
worked out way better than I thought
this is great the end I'd like to
sprinkle them with a little of this red
or some really big ones and here they
are little tiny strawberry strawberry
cheesecake was actually pretty good
this is the first animal looking food
that I've ever seen you been hey
no offense it's cool it's funny I mean
that in a mean way it's true ask them
they know should I just eat it just eat
it
I haven't try to get either so we'll see
when you try first oh hey look fire I
quit it is Dom late' as matt said yeah
it's done let that's a great some thick
one it could use a little like Hershey's
chocolate some dark chocolate mmm oh no
that's suggestion thank so much for
watching if you want to make some dumb
liturgy scag strawberries a while who
need Sean Pokemon go to the Macdonald
Jerry